but we begin this morning with secretary
of state lincoln's warning about
russia's assault on ukraine saying the
offensive now in its second week will
get worse before it gets better his
assessment comes as russia continues a
broad range of attacks across the
country moscow describes the onslaught
as a special operation to capture what
it regards as dangerous nationalists the
u.n ambassador to the united states says
the catastrophe was averted after russia
fired at europe's largest nuclear power
plant in southern ukraine friday but no
radiation was released and this morning
questions over a potential effort to
help some besieged residents get to
safety chris livesay begins our coverage
in the western ukrainian city of la vie
chris good morning
good morning a cease-fire was planned in
the strategic port city of mariupol and
volnovaca this morning in order to allow
for humanitarian evacuations but that
life-saving effort has stalled amid
reports that russian shelling continues
heavy fighting has raged for days in
mariupl
at a hospital a father sobs over the
body of his 16 year old son
deaths that could have been prevented
ukraine insists
if nato enforced a no-fly zone over
ukraine
something it decided against on friday
lest it risk a direct altercation with
russia
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said blood was on their hands
from this day all the people who die
will die because of you he said
russia claims they're not hitting
civilians releasing videos of missiles
launching at precision targets but
on-the-ground evidence tells a different
story
this is a nightmare how is this possible
this woman cries in the northern city of
chernikev just look at this
despite a slow start to the invasion
frontline fighting is closing in on kiev
itself
these jets bombing the city of erpine
next door
and with russian tactics becoming more
and more diabolical nato secretary
general accusing them of using banned
weapons
we have seen the use of
cluster bombs which will be in
in violation of international law
even nuclear power plants are in the
crosshairs u.s officials said the world
narrowly avoided a catastrophe during
russia's siege of europe's biggest
nuclear power plant one that ukraine
said could have been 10 times worse than
the chernobyl disaster
all of it sparking europe's worst
humanitarian crisis this century
more than a million refugees have fled
the country already on par with the
number of refugees who were displaced
from syria iraq and afghanistan in 2015.
dozens come to this shelter here in the
western city of levive before leaving
the country
that's four-year-old andre exhausted
after 20 hours of sleepless escape his
father stayed behind in their besieged
city of harkiv now he only has his mom
and his big brother
every day begins with a text to our
relatives says 16 year old dennis we ask
are you alive
the u.n warns more than 4 million people
that's about 10 percent of the ukrainian
population could be displaced in the
coming weeks but not all ukrainians are
leaving the government says more than 66
thousand men have come home to fight
michelle
chris lives say thank you